stephen king's epic is finally returning
to the screen as a 10-episode
mini-series from a visionary director
and featuring an all-star cast
not to mention a new ending conceived by
king himself here's everything we know
the stand is a massive sprawling
narrative that covers the length and
breadth of america
taking readers from new york city to
maine and from nebraska to las vegas
in the midst of all that king creates a
massive ensemble of good people bad
people and those who lie in between
the earliest casting news for the series
revealed stars including james marsden
as stu redmond amber heard his nadian
cross
odessa young as fran goldsmith and henry
zaga as nick
andros all four of them major players in
the struggle that makes up the book's
core
later casting announcements throughout
the fall of 2019
revealed that nat wolfe joined the
series as the villainous lloyd henry
while jovanna depo will play rockstar
larry underwood
brad william henke will play tom cullen
and greg kinnear will play glenn bateman
two more key names marilyn manson and
the flash star ezra miller have also
joined the series in still mysterious
roles
of course arguably the most important
casting decision in the series arrived
when the production had to select the
major players on either side of king's
good versus evil struggle
the benevolent mother abigail and the
sinister randall flagg
ultimately these roles went to the
legendary whoopi goldberg and the always
compelling alexander skarsgard
respectively setting the stage for a
battle for the ages
you must make your stand the stand was
originally published in 1978 and later
expanded into an uncut edition that
introduced several hundred pages of
previously deleted material in 1990
it's one of king's most ambitious novels
both in size and in scope
and it all begins with the accidental
release of a deadly superflu
the first part of the novel chronicles
the spread of this plague dubbed captain
trips as it kills nearly everyone in the
united states and beyond creating a
wasteland
the few remaining people who prove
immune to the virus feel themselves
drawn to two polarized supernatural
forces
one is a kindly old woman in nebraska
named mother abigail and the other is a
denim-clad demon in human form named
randall flagg
ultimately all of the remaining
survivors are compelled to choose a side
in the coming war
as mother abigail's followers settle
into the free zone of boulder colorado
and randall flagg takes over the mecca
of sin that is las vegas
before it's all over the remaining
representatives of humanity will have to
stand together against the darkness with
the fate of the world at stake
work on some form of adaptation for the
stand dates back to the late 1970s
shortly after the novel was published in
the documentary just desserts the making
of creep show writer director george a
romero recalled that
after he and king began discussing
working together on a project for the
first time
they grew very interested in adapting
the stand as a motion picture
instead the pair of horror masters
turned their attention to the more
achievable creep show anthology film
and the stan's journey to the big screen
was never fully realized as the project
ultimately lapsed into development hell
fortunately king's projects have a way
of coming back to life
in 1994 more than 15 years after it was
published the stan finally made it to
the screen as a massive six-hour
mini-series on abc
king adapted the mini-series from his
novel with director mick garris at the
helm
king and garrus had already worked
together on sleepwalkers and would again
on riding the bullets and the
mini-series versions of the shining and
bag of bones
the mini-series sported a massive
star-studded cast and was a radiant
smash for abc
earning viewers in 19 million homes on
each night of its broadcast
it ultimately won two primetime emmy
[Music]
awards
the stand is such a massive story
following so many different characters
it's also a book that leaves a fair
number of loose ends present for the
reader to contemplate
yes there is a major confrontation near
the end of the novel and it does resolve
in a definite way
but king left plenty of doors open in
the saga if not to continue it then at
least to let his readers decide certain
things for themselves
now we're getting more of the story in
august of 2019 cbs all access revealed
and king confirmed that the final
episode of the new mini-series will be a
new
coda to the original novel that will
explore more of what happened to the
major characters after the novel's
climax
while we still don't know exactly what
this coda will consist of and it will
likely be kept under wraps until it airs
stephen king confirms he's had some
version of this new ending in his head
for three decades and he's looking
forward to finally showing it to the
world
after years in development the stand
finally entered production in september
of 2019. the series is masterminded by
josh boone best known for films like the
fault on our stars and the recently
released
seemingly cursed new mutants boon a
lifelong king fan who read the author's
work in spite of his strict parents will
direct the series which he also co-wrote
with ben cavill
king himself has endorsed this
adaptation and personally scripted the
final episode as a new ending for the
overall saga
king's son novelist owen king will also
serve as a producer on the series
king said i'm excited and so very
pleased that the stand is going to have
a new life on this exciting new platform
the people involved are men and women
who know exactly what they're doing
the scripts are dynamite the result bids
to be something memorable and thrilling
i believe it will take viewers away to a
world they hope will never happen
viewers will get to fall into that world
soon enough the series premieres on
december 17th
and airs weekly check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you